ANN: I'm here to
introduce Max Gladstone.
When Max came to audition
for the writers group
that we are now both
a part of, my hopes
were not particularly high.
We'd had a couple
of folks try out,
and their writing was mediocre
and, more importantly,
their critiquing style was
very soft and very bland.
"Oh, I liked this story a lot.
It's really nice."
The unofficial motto
of our writers group
is that we're cruel
because we care.
And Max fit right in.
He was a magnificent contrast
to the previous people
that we'd had.
His story was nothing like
anything we'd read before.
There was no trite retelling
of "The Wheel of Time".
There were no Isaac
Asimov knockoffs.
And his crits were brutal
in the best possible way.
He would tell you that your
magic system was not coherent.
It didn't make sense.
But without going into
the Brandon Sand--
Sandenburg?
Yes, there we go.
SPEAKER 1: Sanderson.
ANN: Brandon Sanderson level
of, "and the magic system
is the whole story."
This weekend, he critted
one of my stories
and I ended it and
I put, holy crap,
I didn't realize I had
that many problems.
Oh, this is awesome.
It's like having a readability
reviewer for your prose.
Max has readability.
He crits our work,
without a linter,
for style, for content, for
repetition, and ultimately,
for originality.
Max takes his stories
and he'll find two
completely disparate things,
like economics and blood magic,
and shove them together.
And the net result
is that we end up
with something like
"The Craft" verse,
where we all really
enjoy what we're
reading because we've
never read it before,
but it has all of
the bits and pieces
that we're already familiar with
so we don't sit there and go,
I am confused, and
instead you go,
what's going to happen next?
And so on that note, my friend
and also an excellent author,
Max Gladstone.
[APPLAUSE]
MAX GLADSTONE: Thanks so much.
When Ann started talking
about the first meeting
that I was at BRAWL, I
suddenly remembered--
because I'd never had any
experience with doing a fiction
critique in the way that it's
typically done in the science
fiction fantasy circles before.
I had done a couple of
fiction classes in college.
I wrote a lot on my own.
And I had bashed around a bunch
of fanfiction with friends.
So when I sat down
to read the stories,
I got out the red pen
was going line by line
with the crosses and the
circles and the arrows
and the this is that, and
is that, is that, is that?
And it's amazing that
you guys didn't just
set me on fire after the
ends of that meeting, but.
It was enormously helpful, also.
I thought I might read a little
bit from the beginning of Ruin
of Angels," which is the sixth
book in The Craft Sequence
series, which my agent continues
to groan whenever I describe
it that way.
I tell him, they're
different things.
They're different things.
A series is the
sum of a sequence.
And then he told me that
the next time he sends out
a book of mine on
submission, he's
going to just replace the bio
with, "Max writes some stuff."
So fair deal.
Power relationships in
everything, I guess.
So I'm going to read the
first chapter and then
a bit of the second
chapter, that I imagine
you guys might get a
kick out of, and talk
a little bit about the books,
about where the ideas are
coming from and
where they're going,
open it up for questions,
and hopefully we
can have a nice chat.
Chapter one.
Ley built her sandcastle
below the tide line.
Kai warned her, of course.
What else was an
older sister for?
When Ley chose her spot
and planted her flag,
Kai said, "It will drown."
That last word tugged at her,
as if it left a hook in her lip.
She almost apologized,
but stopped herself.
Drown was the right word.
You couldn't avoid words
just because they hurt.
When Ley sculpted the
gap-toothed ramparts of her
keep, like castles from the
kind of Schwarzwald fairy tale
picture books where
kids got eaten,
Kai said, "You see, that's
the tide line up there,
where the seaweed's drying."
When Ley carved a curtain wall
with a bright blue trowel,
packing wet sand
between her palms,
Kai said, "Your wall's too
thin to keep the water out."
"It's not to keep the
water out," Ley said.
"It's to keep out our enemies."
"You don't have enemies."
Ley shrugged and dug her moat.
Mom wasn't there to help.
Today was a mourning day.
She'd gone with her sisters
to Kai's father's grave
to paint her face with
ashes and sit naked, alone,
until the tears came.
She had grieved with her
children, noble and sharp
in mourning white, the day the
bearers brought her husband
home.
She stood chin out, brow
high, eyes bright and black,
impassive as a Penitent
on the outside.
Each body holds multitudes,
the old songs sang.
As a mother, she
helped her children
mourn their shipwrecked father.
As a wife, as a woman, as
someone who had lost a friend,
she needed time alone to break.
She left Kai in charge
because Kai was older
and because Kai didn't
set things on fire just
to see what color they burned.
But Ley only had
the vaguest grasp
of the meaning of the
phrase "in charge,"
and Kai knew better
than to test her younger
sister on this point.
She still had bruises from
the last time she tried.
So Kai left Ley to work
and climbed the beach
to build her own castle
clear of the coming waves.
The sand was drier here
and didn't pack as well,
so she brought a halved
coconut shell to the surf,
filled it with water, and
carried it up the beach
to moisten the sand.
She built a spreading
bay city like Kavekana,
with a mountain behind
it like Kavekana'ai,
and studded the shoreline
with pebble statue Penitents
watching seaward for the
return of long-gone gods.
Heroes.
Fathers.
Each time she went
back to the ocean,
her sister's city had grown.
Ley excavated alleys
with her fingertips
and cut decorations on rooftops
with a sliver of bamboo.
From above, her city
looked intricate
as a Craftwork diagram or
a work of high theology.
Ley, kneeling, brooded
in her swimsuit,
brows low as if to cut off
the half of the world that
didn't concern her--
the beach, the volcano
rising inland, her sister.
She bit her lower
lip as she worked.
"You have to do
something," Kai said.
She chose her words carefully.
That was the joy of words--
you could control them
when all else failed.
"Or the whole thing
will fall down."
Up the beach, bigger kids
shouted and screamed.
A pale-skinned
Iskari tourist girl
dove to return a volleyball
serve and fountained sand
where she fell.
The sea lay calm to the
horizon, but no one swam.
The red flag was up
today, gallowglass
swarming beneath the water with
their long, stinging tendrils,
though they could not
be seen from shore.
White sails bellied on the bay.
Cutters and dinghies
and barques wheeled
in defiance of the
massive container ships
moored near West Claw,
at the deepwater port.
"You weren't listening."
Ley didn't look up.
Fine.
Kai Let Ley build
her doomed city.
Kai marched back up the beach.
She added houses to her
island and dug its bay deep
for the tide,
rolling in, to fill.
Standing, she judged it good.
Then she turned back.
Ley's metropolis
sprawled on shore.
She'd worked out in a spiral
from that central keep, spread
townhouses and factories,
extended her lanes as she
came around to them again.
Kai knew the world she
had built from sand,
but she knew Ley's world,
too, though she'd never
seen it before.
Those broad thoroughfares with
the divided roads and sidewalks
were commercial streets--
no, processional
boulevards, down
which ancient emperors
once marched in triumph,
bookended by arches.
There were palaces there
high temples, here a factory.
To the north, alleys grew
so narrow Ley could not
have made them with her
fingers, must have dredged them
with her bamboo strip.
She had found a dream
city inside them both
and made it real.
And the tide rolled in.
Ley's hands didn't stop.
The rest of her knelt rigid
beside the districts she
shaped, while her thin fingers
carved and built and stroked
sand smooth.
Kai grabbed her coconut
shell, ran below Ley's city,
and started to build a wall.
She built artlessly because
art was not the point.
She did not know why
Ley ignored her, why she
made this weird, familiar city.
She did not know why Ley left
glittering traces of her soul
in the ramparts
beneath her fingers.
But she suspected.
She could have asked Ley,
taken her by the shoulders
and shaken her and
screamed until she
stopped and tried to explain.
But Ley's face reminded Kai
of Mom's in-morning white,
and the words she might say
if Kai forced her to speak
were words Kai knew she
could not bear to hear.
So she built the wall.
With her hands, she built it,
with her own surging shoulders
and legs, with Mom's thick
fingers and Dad's fierce grit.
She gutted the sand
with her coconut shell.
The sun burned her eyes
and warmed her skin
and covered her with sweat.
"Boy!"
a voice called to her in
Iskari from up the beach--
the volleyball girl, drunk,
in a white bathing suit.
"Boy, you can't stop the tide."
Kai ignored the girl, whose
friends shushed her and tried
to explain.
Kai's wall was more of a hill,
really, with a moat behind it
deep as Kai was tall.
She judged the wall's
height against the tide line
and started to curve upslope
to guard the outer edges
of Ley's city.
She sweat and trembled.
There wasn't time.
She couldn't close the eastern
wall before the tide rolled in.
She knew this and
did not let herself
know, because if she knew,
she would have stopped trying.
An audience gathered
up the beach, tourists
and other monsters drawn by the
two girls striving in the sand.
A skeleton in a
flower-print shirt
watched them,
rolling a newspaper
into a tighter and
tighter cylinder
between his fingerbones.
Kai ignored them
and kept fighting.
The water rose as
she built the wall.
Every wash of surf bore
more sand from the wall
back out into the deep.
Kai wasn't padding
the sands down now,
just digging it, tossing
it up, and hoping.
Behind her, a wave
splashed into the moat.
Wet sand stuck to Kai's feet.
She sank.
The wall cracked.
Salt rivers poured in and
soaked her to her waist.
The north wall sloughed
into the water.
Kai scrambled to shore it
up, but the next rushing wave
tore her feet from under her.
She went down in a
tangle of limbs and foam.
Waves and crosscurrents
tossed her, tumbled her,
and she spilled from
the moat onto the beach.
She spat out saltwater and
sand, and when she recovered,
she looked back,
expecting disaster.
But Ley's city stood.
The waves covered
it and drained way
through carved
alleys that should
have collapsed like Kai's wall.
Ley stared down through
the water and to the wash,
and her city did not die.
Ley's soul shimmered
in the sand.
She had built herself
into this city,
mixing soulstuff into
the sand with water.
And now she stood above
the world she'd made
and willed it real
against the waves.
The sand held its shape.
The city sank, but stayed.
It would not break
while she had breath.
Ley rose like a goddess over her
creation as the tide rolled in.
She stretched out her hands
as if to calm the waves,
and for a moment, Kai
believed they might obey.
Then Ley fell, screaming,
into the dirty water.
She gasped surf, gagged,
choked, disappeared
in the wash and foam.
Kai ran into the water,
caught her flailing sister
around her shoulders, and
dragged her to dry sand.
Ley coughed up fluid,
screamed again,
though she had no breath.
A white phosphorescent
thread wound around her leg,
menacing and tiny--
a gallowglass tendril,
torn free and sent
drifting on the tide
in search of a victim.
Probably not fatal.
Kai gloved her hands
in a gob of seaweed
and pulled the tendril free.
Snot ran from Ley's nose.
Her eyes rolled white
behind slitted lids.
She breathed deep and fast.
Venom leaked through
Kai's makeshift glove
and burned her palm.
With the tendril gone,
Ley stopped screaming
but didn't open her eyes.
Kai slung her sister's
arm over her shoulder
and pushed up with her legs.
She took three steps
and stumbled into water.
Building the wall
had exhausted her.
She could not take Ley's weight.
She ground her teeth and
tried to will herself upright.
She stood, too fast.
Someone else held
Ley's other side--
the Iskari girl in the white
suit, the one who'd called her.
"Boy," she said again in
Iskari, "what was she doing?"
Kai hadn't expected
that question.
She didn't think the
Iskari expected it, either.
She was scared of screams.
That was all.
She didn't know why Ley fell.
Easy to see she'd never suffered
a gallowglass sting before.
A gallowglass would
leave a bright red scar
on that sharp pale skin.
The girl was embarrassed,
like tourists sometimes
felt when they helped
or even noticed locals,
and talking to cover her nerves.
"Playing," Kai replied
in the girl's language
and didn't correct her
about the other part.
The girl helped her
carry Ley upslope.
The crowd drew back as they
approached, clearing space
on the boardwalk.
They set Ley down carefully
beside a discarded resort
brochure.
The skeleton watched them both
from behind ruby spectacles,
newspapers still
clutched in his hand.
He could have done
something, Kai
thought, a Craftsman like that.
All the power in the world
at his beck and call.
Lightnings danced when
he crooked his finger.
He could have stopped
the pain at once.
He adjusted his
spectacles instead.
A lifeguard shouldered
through the crowd.
The girl asked, "Why did she
stay when the tide rolled in?"
Kai didn't answer.
The lifeguard bent low,
took a charm from his neck,
and applied it to the sting.
Blood seeped through torn
skin, but at the charm's touch,
Ley's flesh calmed.
Blood stilled.
Ley stopped shaking and
drew her first even breath.
"She wanted to
save it," Kai said.
Her voice hooked after "save."
Speaking Iskari forced
her to gender the pronoun,
and she wasn't sure
whether she chose right.
She remembered
Ley's expression, so
like Mom's, unwavering
and fierce as pallbearers
approached their gate.
She could have said, save him.
Behind her, the sun
set and the tide
rolled up, the ocean at ease as
if it had never killed a man.
The parapets and pinnacles
of Ley's city melted.
Its arches seeped
out into the deep.
Saltwater filled
Kai's model bay,
and her tiny
Penitents stared out
over the flat, poisoned sea.
"Save what?" the girl asked.
But Kai wasn't sure.
And if she knew,
she would not say.
So chapter 2 starts about
20 years later, give or take
a bit.
Who would break into a
bank to leave something?
The practice is more common
than one might think,
though practitioners'
motives tend
to involve eventually removing
more than they originally left.
You might duck the banks
wards, dodge its constructs
and revenants and
demonic and even
sometimes living human guards,
evade its detection magics,
dance across its
pressure plate floor,
answer ye its riddles three,
and leave a beacon glyph
to guide tunnelers,
or a mechanism that
would disable all that
security during a later, more
forceful raid.
A simple listening
device in the right place
could yield the intelligence
to corner or crash a market
or make a small substantial
killing, literal
or metaphorical.
But few people would break into
a bank just to leave something,
and fewer still would
break in to leave a letter.
So while the mailroom of Iskari
First Imperial in Agdel Lex
noticed that the vellum envelope
that appeared in their priority
delivery box one
workday morning,
sealed with blood-colored
wax and the impression
of a wolfsbane flower, lacked
the customary sender's marks,
the demon on duty
believed this merely
an administrative oversight.
Mortals.
Honestly.
If the letter needed shipping
to the Shining Empire,
or west across the
sea to Alt Coulumb,
or even north to
Telomere, the demon
would have wasted
precious minutes
hunting down the
relevant admin so as
to bill the postage properly.
But an envelope for internal
delivery needed no postage.
Even so, the demon hissed
and pondered taking
bloody, demonstrative action.
She'd warned the admin pool
against using priority flags
for internal mail.
In-building post
went round hourly,
and while some
market developments
did need immediate
response, once you
let people flag
intraoffice mail, even
inane check-ins
mysteriously ended up
marked "triple urgent."
A little bloodshed ought to
help clarify the situation.
The mail demon
consulted the building
register and found-- odd--
the recipient unlisted.
Perhaps it was meant for
outside delivery after all?
But no address or postage.
She closed her many eyes
and replayed in her mind,
as her therapist had suggested,
a comforting series of human
screams, starting with
a 10 on the pain scale
and counting down.
That relaxed her
enough for work.
Then she checked the guest
list and realized her mistake.
Kai Pohala, whoever
she was, was only
visiting the office
for a single day.
The message's sender
couldn't meet her in person
and wanted to be sure the
letter arrived before she left.
Sensible.
Saved postage, even.
No one need die today.
Though you never could tell when
a bleak morning at the office
might look up.
Thank you.
So the book had
been out for a week
when somebody sent me a
message on Twitter saying,
just so you know, I sent
the mail demon portion
to one of the guys
who wrote "Sendmail."
And then I died a
little bit of joy.
So yes.
The Craft Sequence is one of
those threads in a sweater
that you start pulling and
then the entire sweater
starts to unravel after you.
That's kind of how the
sequence has built itself.
Back in 2008, I'd recently
returned from teaching in China
and was looking for work when,
basically, the world economy
tripped and fell
into a wood chipper.
And as I was trying
to piece what
was going on together and
spending a lot of time
wandering around Harvard Law
School, where my wife was
a student at the
time, and sneaking
into student seminars
that had been formed
with exactly that
question in mind-- like,
what just happened?
And as I started seeing
more and more professors
drop out or fly
off to Washington
because, oh my god, the
American financial system
is in the middle of a collapse.
We need to do something
about this right now,
I kind of got this
sense that we were
going through an enormous
apocalyptic moment.
But you couldn't exactly
walk down to New York
and find the
smoking crater where
Lehman Brothers used to be.
You couldn't say,
here is the ruin
of AIG in shatters and
shards upon the mountainside
like the Balrog in
"Lord of the Rings."
It was all happening on
a kind of spiritual plane
of existence, on a realm of
contracts and ideas and images.
And from there, I kept pulling.
A the more I learned, the more
I reached for my arch trad-nerd,
"Dungeons and Dragons"
vocabulary to start describing
what was going on, and also
the religious work that I had
studied--
that I'd learned
from my parents, too.
We have a vocabulary, a very
long-standing vocabulary,
for dealing with enormous,
invisible forces that
guard our destiny, and
it's the vocabulary
of magic and religion.
And so much of what changes
the material conditions
of our lives these days
transpires in a world
that we can't touch or
feel but is, nevertheless,
the same world.
It's a world that sort of
directly affects us, directly
shapes us.
It's not this dualist separation
that we sometimes talk
about in philosophy, depending
on our particular bent.
So it started off with
that-- this notion
that you have bankruptcies that
work a lot like necromancy.
You have corporations
and governments
that work a lot like gods.
You have people who work in--
especially now that
you have a modern model
corporation with a
mission statement
or a set of collective
ideals that everybody
is attempting to strive
for, at least in theory.
It starts to resemble
a priesthood,
or it starts to think of
itself as a priesthood,
depending on who
you're talking to--
the sense of corporate
mission or the sense
of governmental mission.
And then you have,
obviously, the people
who are coming in to pray, the
people who are coming in to use
or to participate
or whose lives are
formed by the decisions that are
made inside the big cathedral
building.
So once I had those threads,
"Three Parts Dead," which
is about basically a bankruptcy
proceeding that's taking place
on a dead god in a
hope of "fixing" him
before his city starts to
fall apart, took shape.
But the more I pulled on that
thread, the more connected
it seems to the
fabric of what it
means to be aware and
alive and operating
in the early 21st century.
And this is where
I say things that
start to get me a
little bit in trouble.
If you go back to look at 1950s
and '60s classic golden age
science fiction,
people anticipated
that we would be
living in a world that
had many of the conveniences
and many of the powers
that our world now has.
We have regular flights up
to resupply the International
Space Station.
There is, in fact, a
kind of Heinlein-esque
or self-styled
Heinlein-esque individual
building private space
planes and things like that
out in the Southwest.
A lot of people were definitely
playing into that image set.
But the old school
science fiction
also anticipates a
world that is much more
end-user knowable
and serviceable
than ours has ended up being.
You have people in
"Have Spacesuit--
Will Travel" who are building
rocket ships in their backyard
fundamentally, or oh, I just
got this space suit kit out
of an ad in the back
of the newspaper
and I can tool it all
together, and now I'm
going to go out to pressure
test the space suit.
These are things that some
people do in our reality,
but it's a more limited class
of people that is doing them.
And for a lot of folks, the
incredibly complicated tools
that they employ on
a day to day basis
to figure out how they're
going to get to the Starbucks
around the corner
might as well be magic.
You have something
in your pocket
that might as well be a
magic mirror, in that you
expect it to behave in a
certain, consistent way.
You propitiate it in
a certain fashion.
You recognize that there
is a system behind it that
has complex interactions,
of which you only
see this tiny little aspect,
this sort of user interface.
And some people know
pieces of what's
happening behind the
glass, but very few--
and I'd wager basically
nobody knows everything that's
happening behind the glass.
The systems that we
use have eclipsed,
even at this reasonably
rudimentary level,
if you're thinking
about the next potential
3,000 years of human
technological development,
if we're lucky and
we get to do those,
have already eclipsed
our ability to comprehend
as individual human actors.
And so it starts to feel
a lot more like magic.
And I think this is
part of the reason
that fantasy has come to own the
airwaves and the movie sphere
recently.
You get science
fiction movies which
tend to be about very
immediate problems-- something
like "Ex Machina," which is a
movie about simulated humanity,
artificial intelligence,
some of the immediate threats
or immediate moral
and ethical quandaries
that we're facing as a species.
But the big blockbusters
are basically
fantasy blockbusters, not
only the explicit ones
like the Lord of the Rings
series or the Harry Potter
films, but also the
Marvel cinematic universe,
the superhero universe,
which is fundamentally
a fantasy setting with a
couple bits of science fiction
that are glommed on.
You have grand, dramatic
action in a world that
is much harder for
individual human beings
to know and control.
And that places
certain challenges
for the writing of fantasy and
for the doing of technology,
also, in everyday life.
As a fantasy writer,
that inspires
me to keep going in and trying
to make fantasy that actually
looks and kind of feels the
way that our world feels-- make
stories that not only
pull people into them,
but are enlightening about
how you relate to a world that
is much bigger, older, more
complicated than certainly
you're told in grade school,
the extent to which we're all
setting out from Hobbiton
as we begin our careers
and are coming to
understand that we're
part of struggles that are
much older and more complicated
than any of us
conceive at the outset,
or at least that many of
us conceive at the outset.
I don't know.
And from the
perspective of somebody
who's out to build
systems, the question
is what sort of illusions
are you presenting?
What sort of surfaces
What sort of rituals
are you creating?
And what are the consequences
of those rituals?
What does the system encourage
people to do to one another
and with one another?
I don't claim to have any
answers to all of these.
I just think that they are
questions that we don't yet
have any set answers for
and that are important
and we need to be living
and thinking through.
And I suggest-- and this
is where I'm going with all
of my books--
that it is worth looking to
older methods of interpreting
unseen forces or vast
forces to understand
how people have historically
related to things like destiny
or the weather, to ask like
what are people's expectations
and how do they relate to
things like, I don't know,
Wi-Fi or persistent
connectivity.
But that's just an
out-there theory
right now that I'm
still working on.
I'd love to have some questions
from the audience right now,
or else I can just
continue babbling about all
of these things for a while.
Anyone have a thought?
AUDIENCE: OK, so
there's no number
in the title of
"Ruin of Angels"--
MAX GLADSTONE: Oh, gosh.
AUDIENCE: And more generally,
it took a long time
before somebody pointed out
to me that the first five are
actually numbered in
chronological order,
despite the order in
which I read them.
And of course, reading
them as they come out,
there are a bunch
of obvious oddities
like reading the
story of an adult
and then getting to finally
see the childhood where
a lot of this came from in
a later book in the series.
But I would love
to hear what you
have to say about the order
of the books and the order
that you think people will read
them in now or in the future
and what the thinking was behind
the chronology of the world.
MAX GLADSTONE: Sure.
Thank you.
For those of you who are
coming more new to my work,
I made a terrible,
horrible, bad mistake
when I started
working on this that
actually, like a
lot of my mistakes,
had very good
reasoning behind it.
So I'll walk you through it.
I loved and still love
Terry Pratchett's novels.
The Discworld books
are, for my taste,
one of the best examples
that's out there
of how to assemble a coherent
complicated, multifaceted world
that we see from a lot
of different angles
and a lot of different points
in time and points of view.
But a frustration I
always had as a kid
getting all of these
books out of order--
living in rural Tennessee and
having a tiny local bookstore--
was that I had no
sense where "Guards!
Guards!"
was with respect to
"The Fifth Elephant
or, even though I could
kind of tell one of them
was coming after the
other, how many books there
were in between,
or when characters
were making an offhand reference
to some adventure they've had,
whether I had just missed a
book or whether the book hadn't
been localized into North
American publishing markets
yet, or what.
For a really long time,
there was a book, "Jingo,"
that was missing
from the city guards
sequence in American
publication,
I guess because they thought
that the word "jingo" was too
weird for an American audience?
I don't even know.
But I had to track down
and finally import it.
Anyway.
Really amazing books,
but what order are
you supposed to read them in?
What order do things
even happen in?
Are you, in fact,
getting the first book
in the series when you
think you're getting
the first book in the series?
So I thought, well, I admire
that kind of random access
approach to worldbuilding for
a couple of different reasons.
One, it gives you
the feeling that I
think we all have in
our lives of coming
into the middle of the story
even as we start embarking
on our own personal story.
You start off and you think you
kind of know what the world is
and how it fits together,
but pretty quickly, you
learn that your initial
conceptions maybe
had some flaws in them.
You needed to build
out your sense
of how the world
is and then revise
your own path accordingly.
So "Three Parts Dead" is a
story that starts in a middle.
Tara Abernathy is beginning
her career as a Craftwoman
and she has certain
convictions about how
the world fits together.
Gods are old-fashioned
and antiquated and like,
oh my god--
so to speak-- why are we
still doing any of this?
I don't understand why
all these religious people
are getting out of it.
Gosh, well, I guess I'll
just chop up their deity,
sew it back together, and move
on with my life, or [INAUDIBLE]
as the case may be.
And that's where
she's coming in.
She understands an initial,
kind of high school
historical viewpoint of what's
happened in the last 150
years of her world, where
the Craft came from,
what happened in the God Wars.
She's very smart.
She's very driven.
She's very good
at what she does,
but she doesn't have
that context yet.
And "Three Parts
Dead" is the story
of her getting some
of that context.
But then we see
the entire picture
from another perspective
in "Two Serpents
Rise," which is the next book.
We see it from the
perspective of a city that
was colonized or conquered
very early in the God Wars
and has since developed
as a world of Craftsfolk
specifically rather than
Tara's perspective, which
is a Craftsperson
who is an outsider
to a religious community.
And Dresediel which Tara,
again and again, talks about as
this really awesome place and
she genuinely loves going to
and really is excited
about, has a whole bunch
of issues that are more
or less invisible to her
but become very
visible when we see it
from the perspective of people
who grew up there and live
there every day.
But of course, they have a
perspective on their own city's
history that is warped by
the narratives of its history
that they've received.
So when we see Dresediel Lex
again in "Last First Snow"
about 20 years
earlier in its run,
we discover that some
things that the characters
thought were true aren't true.
We discover that the narrative
about a particular sort of riot
and uprising that happened
in the city's past
is close to the story that
people are telling about it
20 years on but isn't actually
what people are telling about
it 20 years on.
So you get this
multi-faceted view
of the history of the setting
and of meta-plot, to the extent
there is one in
The Craft Sequence.
You see it from this
facet and then this facet
and then this other
facet over here
and you start to get
a sense for the whole.
This is a challenge
in epic fantasy,
usually, because
often, even if you're
trying very hard
in an epic fantasy,
you get one basic through line.
You get your main characters
or your party of adventurers
who are going around.
And they go to this one city,
and this one city behaves
in a certain way
and it's like, oh,
this is the city of the
super honorable people.
When I was a kid, I loved
reading David Eddings' books.
And David Eddings is the arch
king of this exact thing.
This is the sneaky
person country.
Everyone in this country is
super sneaky all the time.
We have a king.
He's the sneaky king.
We have thieves.
They're extra sneaky thieves.
We have knights who are
honorable but sneaky
about being honorable.
Meanwhile, over here, exactly
one country over-- they
share a border-- it's the
land of super honorable
like southern French
courtly romance people
who are all living
as if they are
in a southern French courtly
romance all the goddamn time.
You can go around the map.
There's the poison
people, and there's
people who like trading a lot.
And it's as bad as--
or as elementally
considered as any "Star
Trek" planet of hats.
And there's a weird--
this might be a
strange word to use,
but there's a weird
sort of imperialism
in thinking about worlds that
way, or in building worlds
that way because, of course,
if you want to privilege
the perspective of our
main character Garion
in the David Eddings books,
for example, as he is traveling
around, it might entirely seem
that this culture over here,
the "sneaky" people, but he's
only been there for two days.
And most of those two days,
he was running for his life
from some orc-type
individuals or getting blasted
with magic or something.
He has no clue.
He showed up and somebody picked
his pocket and his conclusion
was, this is the sneaky country.
Not that places don't have
their own authentic character,
but it's very hard
to get a sense
of what that authentic character
is when seen from outside.
So I jumped around, as I was
writing the books, in history
and in geographic
setting and I thought,
I'm going to make things
really easy for people.
It's obvious what
order I wrote the books
in because it just says
that in the copyright page
and you can see that on Amazon.
Your bookseller will tell you.
It's easy to know what
order they came out in.
But what order do they
happen in chronologically?
I'll just put a
number in the title
of each one saying what order
they fall on the number line.
And then that'll let
me to leave a gap,
and then I can put something
into the gap later on,
and this had confused
people for five years.
This is the classic
case of overdesign.
Excellent feature.
It confuses the
crap out of people.
And I've been getting this same
question, or variations of it,
again and again.
Not to throw you under the
bus for asking the question.
It's a good one.
I get it a lot.
I talk about this because
it is important to learn
from one's own mistakes.
So of course, I thought,
ah, brilliant idea.
I've finished the
first five books.
I've tied them into a knot.
We've filled in all of the
gaps in the number line.
And now what I want to do, that
I've shown this world that's
in the midst of a giant crunch,
where people are desperately
trying to figure out what
happens next-- oh god,
there are no good options.
There seems to be
no good options.
The sad truth of reality is that
entropy always marches forward.
And even if there
are no good options,
you need to start
taking action, or things
are going to start happening
around you, or both.
So the rest of the books in
The Craft Sequence, the idea
is time is going to
be marching forward
and our characters
are going to be
dealing with a rapidly evolving
and worsening situation.
So every book after
this is just going
to be one after the
other after the other,
so I'm just going to take
the numbers out of the title.
Plus, we have a different
cover treatment.
It's sort of like a
season two of the series.
It'll be really intuitive.
And it's not been
intuitive at all!
So I don't know.
I need quality
testers or something.
Well, OK.
So the writing group is-- the
writing group are actually
quality testers for the actual
fictions, and what I need is,
I don't know, a business manager
to come and whop me upside
the head every once in a
while, or I don't know--
this is why I'm very
happy with my new agent.
Anyway.
Long, convoluted answer
to a very simple question.
But my apologies for everything.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So maybe this is
another frequent question
because it's a
little bit related.
But I'm curious if taking
this non-linear chronology
and exploring the reasons for
earlier things, if you ever
get to a point where you
regret a decision that you made
in an earlier book and have a
temptation to retcon something,
and if that happens,
how you deal with that?
MAX GLADSTONE: Yes and also no.
Yes, there have been a couple
worldbuilding decisions
that I made when I was writing
"Three Parts Dead," like names
for calling things,
where it was a little too
close to the name
of something that
was in a real-world culture.
And some of those I caught and
changed, and some of those I've
been living with ever since.
And that's fine.
But in general,
in terms of things
that are not connected
to nomenclature,
like large-scale developments
of cause and effect
through the series, that
hasn't happened so much.
This it partly a
virtue of containing
the stories for each
book to the book
itself, so most of the
cause-and-effect stuff
that happens in a book
is done by the time
you turn the last page in it.
So there are a few state
changes in the world that
need to carry over and I need
to keep track of from book
to book, but I
don't need to keep
track of a timeline of
the internal chronology
of each book in any
subsequent book.
It's also easy to explain
any possible variance
between people's
stories from book
to book as a variance of
their knowledge of history
or as somebody
misremembering something.
There's a sense of the timeline
of the Skittersill Rising,
which was the subject of "Last
First Snow," that isn't really
reflected in "Two Serpents
Rise," which I wrote earlier,
but the only sense of
that timing that we get
is from Caleb, who spends a
decent chunk of the second half
of "Two Serpents Rise"
dying of extreme blood loss
and could reasonably be
said to have a skewed
perspective on the situation.
So it's great.
The other side of it is, my
own angle on worldbuilding
is a little less encyclopedic
than that of many epic fantasy
people.
Personally-- I don't
think there's actually
a right or wrong
way to go about it.
There are just ways that you
naturally go about it or not.
There's the Tolkien angle, where
you accumulate this enormous
worldbuilding document that is
full of all your random ideas
for things, and some of them
connect and some of them don't.
Some of them are going to
be relevant to the books.
Some of them aren't.
You're building the
bottom 90% of the iceberg
so you know what goes on top.
The way that I think of
worldbuilding, especially
in a large work like this,
is kind of like a Go board.
Are people familiar with
the game of Go at all?
I've used this analogy a
couple of times before.
I apologize if anyone
has heard me make it.
But you start off in Go
with 19 by 19 blank board.
You're playing against
another player.
You're each laying
down stones in sequence
to try to basically
wall off sections
of the board with
your color of stones
or their colors of stones.
So you've got a white
player and a black player.
And the trick with the early
stages of the game of Go
is you're rarely playing stones
that are right next to one
another, to build a very tight,
connected wall, because it's
much faster to play
stones that are
all the way on the other side
of the board from one another.
You can build a very loose
network that then you
go back to fill in later.
So in the course of writing
any given book in The Craft
Sequence, I'm laying
a stone over here,
and then I'll mention
something that
happens two continents away or
an author that somebody likes,
and that becomes a stone that's
way over on the other side.
So when I am eventually
writing a book that's
focusing on the upper-right
corner as opposed
to the lower-left corner
that I've been focusing on
in the previous
volume, I'll know, OK,
what do I know about this place?
Well, somebody there really
likes this particular author.
They have very spicy food.
They make rugs.
There's this particular
myth that was echoed.
There's a whale
migration near there.
And I have a lot of freedom
within the minimal constraints
that I've imposed on
myself up to that point.
So by keeping the
framework very loose,
it becomes an aid
to creativity when
I get to actually filling
in that corner of the map.
So no on that level.
I've never really regretted
any major decisions
that I've made
outside of, again,
the name of one or two people.
But yeah, those decisions, and
even those offhand references,
end up becoming huge helps when
it comes to writing a book out
and also offer me
plenty of flexibility
for investigating the
corners of the map
that I haven't
really gone into yet.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned at some point
during your opening
statement that you
were interested in how
people operating in systems
behave in reaction
to those systems,
or how systems might force
them to react to each other
or treat each other.
So that obviously
implies that you've
sort of built political
systems or magical systems
or economic systems
or social systems.
Where do you go for
inspiration, or how do you
develop those in the
course of your writing?
How do I develop the
systems that I develop?
A lot of research is
what it comes down to.
I'm rarely writing
cultures or systems that
are strict [INAUDIBLE]
strict fictional importations
of other cultures,
but I'm often thinking
about a particular region or
a particular sort of conflict
that I can flesh out.
I go to academic anthropology
a lot for this sort of stuff
because anthropology
tends to focus
a lot more on the
ways people respond
to their environment
and the ways
people socially code or socially
react to their environments
than on the specific
evolving physical conditions.
Kavekana, which is where the
initial excerpt that I read
from "Ruin of
Angels" takes place
and where "Full Fathom
Five" takes place,
is set on a vaguely
Polynesian island.
And I was really interested
in the question of cargo cults
and the development
of local religions
in the context of a much
larger imperial system.
So I read a lot about
how those came to be
and what role they were
playing, and it turned out
to be much more nuanced
than I'd initially thought
from your reflexive sense.
Oh, the cargo is dropped off
and then you worship the cargo.
I started seeing it.
And anthropology texts were
talking about it much more
as a revolutionary movement,
or as something that's
happening in response
to a worldview that's
encountering something that's
basically out of its context.
So you have a worldview
in which the sea is kind
of the border of the known.
You can travel between islands,
but there's always the sense
that there's this enormous,
vast expanse of water beyond all
of the islands that you know.
Maybe you can cross it.
Maybe you can't.
But what's over there
is fundamentally weird,
and that's where the
ancestors go when they die.
And then all of a
sudden, these people
show up in ships from all
the way across the world who
talk about coming
from a land that
is across that
unknowable gulf of water,
and who seem fundamentally
different from anyone
that you've encountered before.
And you can start
talking about them
as spirits in a
way that recognizes
that they are certainly
not from wherever you are.
They're not part of
the deal that you're
a part of with your
landscape and your culture.
And the initial is like--
oh, it's sort of silly.
The initial experience upon
reading about a cargo cult--
like, how weird, they
are talking about a rifle
as a magical object--
becomes a lot more
sensible when you recognize
that a colonial settlement
doesn't have any of the tools--
the European colonial
settlements in Polynesia
doesn't have any of
the tools that they
need to build a lot of
the technological goods
that they're importing.
You can say, oh,
yeah, we made this.
The hell you did.
Can you show me
the factory that's
going to make you a rifle?
You guys are planting exactly
the same crops we're planting.
You have slightly
weirder houses,
and you have stuff
for your dress,
but you're fundamentally human.
There is absolutely no
way you made this thing.
Obviously what's
happening is you
are intercepting the shipments
that our ancestors are
sending to us and
using them against us,
so there's going to
be some redress coming
when that happens.
You're getting this from
a supernatural agent
because obviously it's
a supernatural agent.
And that jump of conceiving
of a foreign set of power
relationships and a foreign
set of technological material
conditions in a truth system
that you grew up using--
sort of ritualizing a
different people's knowledge--
is a process that I
find really fascinating,
and that's something that
academic sociology gets
into a lot.
So I found James C. Scott's
"Seeing Like a State"
enormously useful in building
the girders of this approach.
There's a great book by Michael
Taussig called "The Devil
and Commodity Fetishism
in South America," which
is about what happens when
you take people who don't have
a capital economy
and you thrust them
into the conditions
of a capital economy.
And one of the things
that can happen,
anyway, is that they
conceive of the capital
economy as witchcraft
and corporate existence
as a fundamentally satanic
mode of being, which I think
is pretty cool.
You start seeing when
Colombia is colonized
and when villages are forcibly
shifted over into a plantation
mode of agriculture.
People are either
enslaved or put
into exploitative
agriculture-company-store kind
of situations.
You start seeing attempts to
describe what interest is.
Like, what is this
thing where I have money
and then I have more money?
Well, what happens,
you see, is you
plant the money in
the ground and then
you sell your soul to
the devil, and the devil
ensures that more money is
going to grow up from it.
So you get a kind of witchcraft
interpretation of something
that feels like a very intuitive
part of the financial system
to somebody who's
grown up in it.
So those are things
that really inspire me,
and those are
directions that I keep
looking for as I'm trying to
figure out next steps to take
The Sequence.
I want to thank
everybody for coming.
And if you guys want to come up
and continue the conversation
afterwards, I'm totally
happy with that.
We have some books
that I can sign, also.
And thanks so much
for having me.
[APPLAUSE]